[Music]  he what stop cuz now Khloe Kardashian  opens up about starting a family someday  with her beau Tristan Thompson the 32  year old reality star got candid about  her relationship with the NBA pro during  the season 13 finale of Keeping Up with  the Kardashians she said I want to have  kids with you did it interested in was  like a man if you get pregnant you could  make heidi jeans for good american you  so feeling like supportive and swift has  never had such a nice nice nice person  the couple who have been dating since  september might even have a family as  big as the Kardashians one day Tristan  and I definitely talked about starting a  family um he wants to have like five or  six kids  Chloe shared some cute footage with her  man she gushed over their next chapter  together I am really really excited  about my future  just me interesting like we're doing so  well and I'm looking forward to see  where all that goes  [Music]  you